[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اعقاب القصف المتبادل
بين اسرائيل والفصائل الفلسطينيه عمليه في
الاغوار الشماليه تسفر عن مقتل مستوطنتين
واصابه ثالث بجروح خطيره ورئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي يامر بتعبئه جنود الاحتياط في
حين باركت حركه حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
العمليه دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس
تقول ان 130 الف مصلل ادوا صلاه الجمعه
الثالثه من رمضان في المسجد الاقصى حيث
توافدوا من القدس وبلدات الداخل ومن ارجاء
الضفه الغربيه رغم تضييقات الاحتلال بنشره
نحو 2300 جندي في القدس وتشديده الامني
على حواجز الضفه الغربيه بعد قصفه عشره
اهداف في غزه وثلاثه جنوبي لبنان نتنياهو
يقول ان على سكان غلاف غزه ان يكونوا
مستعدين لايام صعبه قريبا والفصائل
الفلسطينيه تقول ان الرد على القصر
الاسرائيلي
ضمن قواعد الاشتباك بينما يؤكد لبنان
التزامه بالحفاظ على الهدوء ويقدم شكوى
الى مجلس الامن الدولي الى الاردن حيث
خرجت مسيرات تنديدا باعتداءات الاحتلال
على المسجد الاقصى المبارك والمصلين فيه
وفي لندن نظم محتاجون وقفه امام سفاره
الاسرائيليه رفضا للاعتداء على الاقصى في
حين نددت مسيرات في الشمال السوري ومدينه
طرابلس اللبنانيه بالعدوان الاسرائيلي على
غزه والقدس الى اللقاء